今日は事務所です皆さんコップ使ってますですよ
皆さんコップ使ってますでしょうか保育飲み物を飲むときにこうやってピってて
ごくごく甘え家で飲むんですけどどっこのぽっぺ
ネットで買ったんですけども壊れないコップらしいです
スカンディナビアっていう海外のメーカーが出してるらしいんですけどもお腹上だけで
ネットとか見ても恒例ない
って書いてあるんですよまじでアマゾンで買ったんですけどもう amazon で
買う時ももう割れないコップってタイトルで打っててう黄金は持ってる持ってるって
思って買ってしまいましたデータデータデータはもうほらもうほらはれないコップって
書いてあります症かなと4.5
かかる高い福岡は帰ってことは本当にもれないってこと
これははれなそうですよねただ網を破れない
っていうんだったらよっぽどは出ないんだろうなということで今回断れないコップは
ぶっ壊すみようと思います
バッハみんな勘違いしないでくれ
今回うんじゃあここやなんと断れないコップをつくった巣管理の皆さんにわざわざ強化
プって動画を撮っております
ご覧くださいたいはず目3戦9倍町しまう
tano
me
一応聞いてみたんですねはんだってたらってもも残せたらん
pop つけた人に許可とってやりゃいいんじゃねっていうことにたどり着いてあの
わざわざ海外の方に許可を取っていきましたこれでエンターの心入ったら街本当にあの
作った人の立場にもなれということになりますからね私はいろいろ構図一件をしてみ
たいですよくの pop が強すぎて壊れないということを言ってるんだったら何か
落としてみたいながいろいろしてはしたいいですけどテストしたいんですけどいいです
かっていったらよろしくお願いしますということでございますのでこうしてきまーす
かっこいいよって
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ああああああ
[音楽]
えっ
パパ
を
[音楽]
パパたっ
あっはい
あ
ああああああ
8もぅ
[音楽]
ピラー
ああああああ
バッハ
バー
ああああああ
[音楽]
俺だーッ
あああああ
[音楽]
ん
います
やったろう
おおーーぬふぅあああ
うんっ
はああっ
の
あれ
って
[音楽]
物理的な講義が効かずとも熱にやら弱いかもしれません
恋
[音楽]
焦げ臭い
あっあ
すげー
うざざ
ん
ええええええ
tan
はぁ
[拍手]
あっ
まいりましたーーーん
me
teame
wh 8版